>> Welcome to another Authors at Google event.
I'm very excited to introduce Tyler Shores.
He was a former Googler and also works on
Authors at Google program. Today, he'll be
discussing his contribution to the book, "Heroes
and Philosophy," which is the first book to
examine the philosophy behind the hit show
Heroes. Before Heroes, he studies another
hit show, The Simpsons. At UC Berkley were
he received his undergraduate degree in English
and Rhetoric, Tyler used the Simpsons as his
primary case study to teach a class on Postmodern
Parody and Subjectivity in Mass Culture. If
you're like me, you'll be excited to here
that Tyler has three more books coming out.
So keep watching your favorite shows, you'll
definitely have an intellectual justification
for watching them. While not writing, Tyler
is a project manager for the Center for Civic
Education. Please join me in welcoming Tyler
Shores.
>> SHORES: All right. Well, thank you for
that. It feels very nice to be back here and
also a little disorienting, I think, because
I can--I can't even count the number of times
I've been on the other end of this author's
talks and secretly fantasizing that, boy,
I wish, you know, one day it would be me speaking
at the podium. So, here I am now and, hopefully,
I don't blow this. And I also want to say
that, you know, I think it's safe to assume
I'm not anywhere near as rich and famous as
pretty much anyone who has ever done an author's
talk. So I think it's okay for me to say that,
like the first time I saw, you know, something
I've written on the BookShelf that Barnes
and Noble ordered, it was pretty cool. I took
a picture of it and I think I may post it
on Facebook because it was pretty exciting.
And I'm going to share one funny story and
get down to the, like more interesting stuff
that--because it's too good of a story not
to share. Apparently, a previous Authors at
Google, a guest, said during the course of
his talk that women who would go on dates
with him, with it, inevitably do a Google
search on him, and he remarketering, during
his talk that, oh the YouTube talk with the,
you know, inevitably be one of the search
results that is, his stalkers in waiting with
the, would see on there.
So, assuming there's anyone else in the world
besides myself who Googles my name, I'd kind
of like to test theory so--we'll see, okay.
See the sad part is I could tell jokes and
funny stories like probably the whole time
but actually took notes that I can say more
on topic because the reason why I'm here of
course is talk about Heroes and Philosophies.
So first of all why a book, why a book on
the "Heroes and Philosophy"? And I want to
answer that question by touching briefly on
some specifics and then speaking more generally.
One of the things that makes heroes specifically
such an appropriate fit for a book about philosophy
is that there's a number of very philosophically
interesting themes that are kind of in a woven
through the, excuse me, the course of the
narrative of the show, or if not themes that
we use topics that are, you know, lend themselves
very easily that philosophical reflection.
For example, you know, we have a show that
is about Heroes and Villains at Core which,
you know, therefore, it leads us to questions
on the nature of good and evil, which I'm
going to talk about more in a little bit.
The character such as Hiro Nakamura and/or
Sylar represent good and evil in the very
straight forward sense with characters like
Heroes say people and characters like Sylar
who kill people. We have many other characters
in the show that are painted with much subtler
with shades of gray. We have like, you know,
Nathan Petrelli and Noah Bennett who--they
do make us ask this question about like, what
exactly is a hero or villain on the show?
And that's one of the things for people who
followed it from season one through the upcoming
season four. They've, you know, they've done
something interesting with this. The show
is kind of question, just kind of moral uncertainty
of the status and some of the characters.
So that's one of the philosophical, you know,
underpinnings of the show that I want us to
talk about a little more. And another thing
I think that is probably worth mentioning
is that philosophy is not just something that
philosophers do. The argument is that—well,
I would say that philosophy is something that
we all do all of the time. It really just
becomes a question not so much if we're doing
philosophy but rather, that what degree of,
you know, like how cognizant are we of the
philosophy that we're already doing. When
we think about the ultimate meaning of something,
whatever it is, we're doing philosophy. When
we question the rightness or the wrongness
of a person's actions, we're doing philosophy.
When we--we wonder to ourselves what kind
of person we are or why we find something
meaningful, we're doing philosophy. So, a
book that combines a popular culture in philosophy
kind of--hopefully, it will make us more aware
of the fact that philosophy is much closer
to us in our everyday lives than we normally,
usually realize. So, let's talk specifically
about how Heroes and Philosophy works though.
I would think that good stories and good philosophy
are alike and that they carry a certain resonance,
like they touch upon certain elements of the
human condition and human existence that like,
you know, they begin to take on aspects of
the universal. We can't help but relate to
these things and that's, you know, one thing
that Heroes is a good story, is a good show,
is inherently interesting to us in this way.
There's something about Heroes and I'll talk
about this in a little more detail, but like
you know, on--in almost like archetypical
level, like there are certain like, you know,
like very fundamental questions that I think
we try to--we've tried really hard in the
book to kind of bring out and discuss a little
more. But one of the reasons why I think Heroes
and Philosophies such a cool topic is--the
whole notion of the superhero, [INDISTINCT],
kind of represents our own modern day mythology
when we're really start to think about it.
If you think, for instance, like of ancient
Greek and ancient Roman Mythology we have
these larger than life figures. But at the
same time, we have these characters that--on
the one hand we want them to be beyond the
scope of, you know, like human lamentation
and human potential, but at the same time,
we want them to be deeply flub, we want them
to have their own, you know, shortcomings
and then in that way we kind of see more of
ourselves in these characters. So we want
them to be both above us, you know, like you
know, beyond the can of human limitation but
at the same time, we don't want them to be
any better than us, so that's kind of like
the--if we think about mythological figures,
that is sort of in a way what, like the superhero,
[INDISTINCT], kind of does for us if you think
of the help--excuse me--like any of the characters
nowadays like, you know, Spiderman or any
of this other characters. You know, the other
superheroes and they have their, you know,
their things that make them super but, they
certainly have things to make them very, you
know, human too and that's something that
I think heroes does very well. Like we have
these characters who were really supposed
to be like, you know, the promise of the show
is what if ordinary people were just to wake
up with super powers one day and like, you
know, it brings you through that process,
and philosophically gets kind of interesting.
Hiro, Hiro Nakamura is a great character for
a number of reasons and like he fits this
per--first of all, his name is Hiro. But the
second of all like, you know, just think about
it for a second if you've watched the show,
he struggles to do the right thing, he struggles
to like, you know, find himself and try to
like fulfill his destiny of what it is he's
trying to do. That makes it inherently more
relatable to us. People in real life can be
brave, they can be bold, they can be decisive
but, in real life, people are just as likely
to be cowardly and indecisive and make the
wrong decisions so there's that element too.
There's the fact that we want heroes who can
do the right thing but struggle to do that.
The characters make for interesting drama
in the show because of these flaws. Like,
there's something oddly, comforting about
valuable heroes I think. And when we imagine--I
think this says something too about the way
in which we kind of imagine like our heroes
fragilities, it says something about us too.
On a deeper level, we kind of want imperfect
heroes. We want heroes, we don't have it easy
because we are not, we are imperfect and we
don't have it easy and we see some--it's easier
for us to see more of ourselves in this kind
of struggles. For those of us that have been
regular viewers of the show, that first season
was appealing to me for some of these reasons
that I'm just talking about. I think season
one was a very good season of, you know, television
period. The idea of taking, you know, like
I said, seemingly ordinary people and like
putting them in this contexts were they have
to discover that they're not as ordinary as
they thought and they have to discover that
they're different than who they thought they
were. This is, you know, these are things
that are not hard for us to imagine like,
you know, forget the super powers thing but
it's not hard for us to imagine that we have
to, you know, we're putting a position were
all of a sudden we're unfettered from our
normal context and we have to think in terms
of who are we and, you know, why are we doing
these things. So there are some like interesting
things, like these larger issues that I'm
talking about. But, speaking of interest,
I want to talk specifically about what I wrote
in the Heroes and Philosophy volume, and the
topic was on time and meaning in Nietzsche
and heroes. Time to me is such a philosophically
interesting topic. I--our understanding of
time on the most like fundamental levels really
does inform a lot of, who we are as people,
as human beings. Many philosophers have argued
that, you know, man or woman is essentially,
a temporal being that we define our existence
and/or identity in terms of time. On a less
like you know, lofty level like, we can pretty
much say that we are obsessed with time. Like,
to see how this possessiveness plays out,
we just need to look at, you know--like think
about for a second, like the language that
we use when we're talking about time. We're
always aware of the ways in which we spend
our time. When we're enjoying ourselves, we
say that we're having the time of our life.
When we are disappointed with the outcome
of something, we say that was a waste of time.
When we're at work, we say that we're on the
clock. When we are not at work, we say that
we're taking time off or we're on vacation
time and so on and so on, you like the idea.
But like time has that, like omnipresent sort
of feature on our everyday lives, just count
for instance the number of ways that you can
tell time, I've got my clock, I've got my
phone, I've got--there's a little time were
up here, but just think about in your home
or your office, or your apartment or whatever
like the ways to tell time, the ways to measure
time, or ways to be reminded of time are everywhere
on our--in on everything. So it's interesting,
it's interesting to think about and, you know,
underlying that cause, it's almost like--I
don't know what it's called, it almost like
in uncertainty or a feeling that if we're
not paying attention to time, we're worried
that something is going to happen to us, or
some--that something is going to happen to
time, so there's that--that omnipresent awareness.
The only two places that you can't see reminders
of time, at least the ones that I could think
of were the post office and casinos so the
places that you're wasting time the most are
the places where you don't want to be reminded
of time. But anyways, that's sort of like
mindfulness of time and meaning is kind of
what, where I decided to write about and that
it's certainly a major theme within Heroes.
Hiro, the character, you know, his super powers,
the ability to stop time and to move backwards
and forwards through time. So there's that
kind of, you know, sci-fi thought problem
that we can sort of, sort of play with. There's
a moment in the show when Hiro--very early,
it's like the second or third episode. He's
trying to explain how his powers worked to
his friend Ando, and he said, "People think
that time runs in a straight line," he draws
a straight line but he actually runs like
this, in a circle. So, that is extremely significant
to me I think in terms of, when I talk about
in the chapter on Nietzsche--the general premise
of Nietzsche's ideas is what he calls the
eternal recurrence. That time isn't whinier,
the time doesn't necessarily run in a straight
line but he wants us to think that time can
run over and over again in the fashion of
like a circle. He uses his idea of the eternal
recurrence ask us to imagine that our entire
life would recur over and over, and over again
in an endless loop of kind of this, you know,
undifferentiated sameness. So, he ask us to
like actually think about this for a second,
"What would you think like what would you
do, what would you response to this sort of
situation?" It's not like this is supposed
to be something that could or would happen,
but he wants to do like, think in terms of
like, you know, how you view your life? Like,
you know, if everything would repeat over
and over, and over again for all eternity.
It supposed to be a thought problem and the
eternal recurrence--what Nietzsche's means
by this is that, everything that has happened
and is happening and will happen, will happen
over and over, and over, and over again. When
we start to think about it in a minute, we're
actually supposed to realize that this is
a horrible, horrible thing. In example from
the show that I could illustrate this is at
the end of season two in hero--for those of
you who have seen the episodes, he traps Adam
Monroe in a coffin. Adam Monroe is like the
bad guy in season two but he's a person who,
you know, like his super powers is to live
really long, so he's several hundred years
old. But, when you think about that for a
second, being alive but stuck in a coffin
basically forever doing the same thing over
and over again which is nothing, that is pretty
much the eternal recurrence in a nutshell,
that's like the--the awful weightiness that
Nietzsche wants to impress upon us. It's supposed
to be awful, it's supposed to be that feeling
of unmitigated, you know, lack of change and
no hope of there ever being a change. So,
it's a thought problem, it's kind of a downer
but that's what philosophy is sometimes. So,
Nietzsche and like I want to quote one of
his works directly from the Gay Science, he
describes the situation in the following way.
"There will be nothing new in it, but every
pain and every joy and every thought, and
every sign, and everything and honorably small
and great in your life will have to return
to you all in the same succession and sequence."
So, time and repetition are prominent themes
in the first season. When you think about
the--like the tag line, for what the show
first became famous for, save the cheerleaders,
save the world, I mean the basic idea behind
that was that, the future mustn't repeat itself
in the present. They saw this like, you know,
post-apocalyptic thing that happens, New York
City blows up, and then they're supposed to
go back into the present to stop the future
from happening. So again, this time and repetition
themes were very prominent in the show even
they're not necessarily spelled out in that
way. So it's clear in the show why we don't
want things to happen like that, why we don't
want things to repeat. We don't want New York
City to blow up, so Hiro travels back in time.
But for Nietzsche he puts to us the question,
"If we could change things to be other than
they were, what does that tell us about ourselves?
Why would we want to do that? Why do we want
thinks to change?" And I'm going to come back
and like try to offer an explanation for the
answer. But, the way when we answer this question
kind of serves as, a way of providing some
sort of insight to ourselves about how we
view our lives and how we view the sort of
way everything should be connected. For Nietzsche,
we understand that a single moment can be
like a fundamental measure of time. We find
moments, if you think about, you know, any
moment in particular, moments are so valuable
because they are so pleading and so transient.
Some people spent their whole lives trying
to pursue a lost moment or waiting for a moment
that never happens. But the idea of the eternal
recurrence is that, what would you--how do
you feel about that moment? That, whatever
it is that you have schemed so highly, if
that same thing were to happen over and over,
and over again, could you possibly like, you
know, care as much about it were to repeat?
No, you couldn't, that's--by definition, it's
that finitude that sense of, you know, fleetingness
that we find so valuable in which we derive
the meaning and, you know, contentment from.
So, it--like, as a thought problem this idea
of everything recurring over and over again
is actually a very interesting one when you
start to apply it to, you know, different
moments in time and different moment from
your life. There's a clear parallel I think
in this regard that Nietzsche's philosophy,
any events that's unfolds in the first season
of Heroes. From the season's final--final
episode which is called "How to stop an exploding
man?" The entire future does seem to hinge
on this one moment when, you know, the ultimate
future that they though was going to happen,
it doesn't happen and it's because of that
one thing that happens without spoiling too
much people; we're interested in the show
but haven't seen it yet. And you know, basically,
things are very different afterwards as results
of that. And approve that, I wasn't like making
all of the stuff up. If you look closely in
one of the episodes from season three, Arthur
Petrelli who's, like he's the bad guy of the
show in that season. He's actually holding
a copy of one of Nietzsche's books: "Thus
Spoke Zarathustra". It's none insignificant
detail, and given the stuff that cover in
the chapter on Nietzsche but, the point is,
the philosophy is there if we care to look
for it. Usually the philosophy isn't quite
as transparent as the character like actually
holding the book--actually it's never that
obvious. Is like a character holding a book
and saying like, you know, this is the philosophy
that we're talking about, but it shows that
philosophy is present in a lot of ways if
we, you know, cared to look for these things
and observe like those sort of details which
is nice and that's why, you know, the approach
of, you know, not only Heroes and Philosophy
but, a lot of similar popular culture in philosophy
books that are, are part of the series. In
the end, the reason for bringing up all this
question about time and repetition, and meaning
is really just to have us consider like if
we think of things purely in terms of--oh,
this is a good moment or this is a bad moment,
do we only think of things in those terms
is/or sometimes can we actually see like a
larger sense of inner connection like, you
know, see that one moment is actually necessary
for another moment, like that's not always
an easy thing to do. There's another very
interesting moment in that first season when
Hiro's future self the--like the bad ass version
of himself, was like the goatee [ph] in a
ponytail and the sword and everything. He
has the string map like it's this very interesting--I
forgot what he calls it other than like, like
this map of advance for like these things
happen in time and he's got--oops, he's got
like strings attached to each of these things
and he says like, you know, this is a map
of time and you can trace like different events
and different people, and where things fell
together, where things fell apart. So, that,
like it's a very fitting analogy I think for
what I'm trying to talk about in the--in the
Nietzsche chapter that there is the sense
of like, you know, one single moment can be
very interconnected. And a lot of times it's
impossible for us to kind of discern like,
you know, how these connections happened but
it's just--like as a metaphor, I just want
you to think about that image of this like
string map with all of these different things.
What would your life look like if it were,
you know, like little push pins and strings,
and like you connect people in events and
times, and everything together? Like I think
that's a very, very appropriate way to kind
of understand what Nietzsche is talking about.
So that's one of the things that, in terms
of philosophical questions that Heroes and
Philosophy discusses. Another thing we should
dealt more into that I mentioned earlier is
the question of good and evil. Are the heroes
really good? That doesn't really--I mean it
sounds like a really obvious and banal question
but right around season three, things start
to get less black and white. Heroes can become
villains and villains can sometimes become
heroes before quickly turning back to villains,
so there's that kind of, you know, again like
more uncertainty and then now, or rather a
nice way I think is presented in the show
is the logo. I'm ripping this off from one
of my co-authors but he'll forgive me. The
Heroes' logo is--in eclipse of the sun, right,
and in Plato's Republic, Plato describe the
sun as basically as symbol for goodness and
knowledge, and like, you know, the intelligibility
of goodness through like, you know, the light
of reason and all these things. If you think
about an eclipse for instance, like the sense
of like, you know, there's something obscuring
the sun, like it suppose to symbolize, could
symbolize, you know, like this sort of like
moral, uncertainty and ambiguity that happens
in the show. So, it's a very fitting metaphor
I think. Without getting to, I think college
electuary for everyone, there--I would just
quickly say there are a number of ways that
philosophers have kind of dealt with this
issue of, you know, good and evil, and like
in a ways which has been conceptualized. Socrates,
for one felt that evil was basically, simply
resulting of insufficient knowledge that,
you know, like everyone--anyone who really
understood what it meant to be good and to
do good, would do good. Like evil and badness,
and more of wrongness was really just, you
know, insufficient and understanding of what
good really was, that was Socrates'--that's
a thumbnail sketch what Socrates, you know,
felt was the, kind of the moral philosophy
there. So, you know, evil wasn't so much evil
in the sake of evil but it was the, the results
of the imperfect knowledge. Nietzsche and
another one of this were is called Beyond
Good and Evil, asks us to think about why
we think of good and evil the way we do. And
what he means by that is maybe definitions
of good and evil are as set as we think they
are. He asks us just for the sake of argument
to consider a time when maybe evil meant then
what good means now, that there is this inversion
of swords between terms. Maybe there could
be an evolution from like, you know, like
what--he's asking us to consider what exactly
is the goodness of good and the evilness of
evil. One of the things that he talks about
without getting into too much more detail
about this was the, Nietzsche suggest that
good and evil could possibly have started
from just like, you know, this means of differentiation
that good and evil without any sort of like
moral evaluation would just simply be a way
of saying, you know, goodness and evilness
could have been a term of like, you know,
me-ness and you-ness. I call myself good,
therefore I call you bad because you're not
me. So in a very like simple like, you know,
kindergarten level, like we understand intuitively
why that could have been the way things were.
In season one, to kind of pick up the theme
again of like more on uncertainty and sort
of like these shades of gray. There's a very
sort of Watchmen like plot for anyone that
seen the movie or the, read the graphic noble
by Alan Moore, which again like I said results
and the blowing up in New York City. There
are a few people who know that this is going
to happen but they choose not to do something
about it. The moral justification is that
they're uniting humanity against the common
threat and that's very Machiavellian sort
of--and to justify the means. And, at one
point, one of the character says, "People
need hope but they trust fear" so this idea,
and one of the episodes that's really good
and really kind of chilling and creepy is
called .07%, and the idea is that .07% of
the human population is an unacceptable lost
until I can ensure against like, greater like
you know catastrophe. So this idea that you
blow up New York City and your, you know,
letting this many people to get blown up but
and then, you know, they are going to go to
that spoiling episode that they're saving
more lives in the process like for the future.
It's good, it's a really good episode and
again, like the first season is--it touches
on like a whole slew; very philosophically
interesting theories were all making for very
good drama I think. Interesting questions
in moral ambiguity that, for me, that shows
you know narrative threat the first three
seasons. And there's a difference I think
between moral ambiguity which is what I've
been talking about and moral compromises.
That's another thing that one of the chapters
in the book talks about Noah Bennett, who's
the horn-rimmed glasses guy. He does some
pretty terrible things, including like torture
and murder, in the service of what he says,
he's protecting his family which, you know,
like if you follow his character like, you
know, that's very important to him is like,
you know, being a good father but it is a
compromise. He's sacrificing some things like,
you know, like killing people and torturing
people if it means protecting the people he
cares about the most. Angela Petrelli, justifies
lighting--New York get blown up for the simple
reason that she considers it a greater good
that's going to result in a better future
for everyone. Nathan Petrelli who's the son
of Angela suggests that super power people's,
like, concentration camps would be a good
idea. It would be a good thing to protect
everyone else from themselves. So there's
this question that's a very politically freighted
argument obviously that liberty can be exchanged
for security. So there's, you know, there's
a very interesting issues here, and on the
one hand, some of these examples--some of
these are very whacked out examples. Some
of them are not as whacked out as others which
make them disturbingly close to home. What
this has to do with us, however, is this notion
again of like moral compromise is not unfamiliar
to us in our every day lives. Maybe not these
specific instances but we understand intuitively
what we, you know, we make trade offs in small
decisions where we're deciding one set of
moral values for another, and that's inevitable,
that's what we do in life whether we realize
it or not. Heroes is also interesting to us.
One of the things, the reason for that is,
in this book--and again, I'll talk about these
kind of shades of gray, this is kind of like
ambiguity between dark and light, black and
white, is that we take for granted this like
black and white, these things between heroes
and villains, and good and bad. One of these
moral sorts of question which I think is kind
of a neat one is: What effect do superpowers
have on society? You know, it's kind of a
silly question but it does like, you know,
it has intellectual merit I think because
if you think about, and we're not even talking
about super powers anymore. How would you
act when you could do things that no one else
could do and no one would be able to stop
you? Asking this kind of questions get some
of the nature of morality, were we no longer
to have like the traditional suicidal checks
of like, you know, discipline and punishment
and this sort of things. Then all are really
is at that point is this moral obligation
to do what we think is right or what we think
is wrong. What would that look like in the
world of Heroes? There's an episode were they
talk about this, but the idea that I'm kind
of hinting out here in short, is the idea
of another philosopher, John Locke, not the
Lost character but the 17th century British
Philosopher and his idea of the social contract.
The social contract basically says that, you
know, Locke means to say, "We live in an orderly
society for a certain reasons." We have certain
rules which we obey because in turn, you know,
we get protection from being innocent in our
society, we're not killing everyone and stealing
each other all the time, that's the balance
[ph]. You're sacrificing some amount of personal
freedom in order to get like the larger protection
and the larger benefits of being part of a
society. Thomas Hobbes talks about this issue
in his state of nature which is very similar
to this idea of the--the outcome of which
is the social contract. Where Heroes comes
in, I mean just for the sake of argument is
what happens to the society when, you know,
let's say, what happens to the society and
its rules when people--some people were no
longer need that, that protection or no longer
have those rules of the society apply to them.
If such people like, you know, where do exist,
like how they would exist, you know, forget
super power for a second but just think. If
they didn't need society in the way that the
rest of us need society like, you know, would
or should, I mean for there, you know, from
their personal standpoint, will they need
to abide by the same rules that we do? It
gets in the questions, in a criminal justice
and all these other things. But philosophers
like Hobbes and Locke, you know, when they
speak about society, they bring up the fact,
the premises of the society is like there's
a need for it. There's a need for society
because we are really more equal than, you
know, sometimes we care to realize or care
to admit as like, you know, living human beings.
In one episode of the show which is called
I Am Become Death, I think this is the fourth
episode of the third season, and it's really
one of the neater episodes of the show. A
super power formula kind of--is distributed
through in this kind of like alternate scenario
and in effect everyone get super powers. And,
essentially, what happens, the result of this
is just a very dark future for everyone. Power
for everyone is much more a blessing than
a curse--at least, that's the thesis that
that episode is sort of putting out there.
Many of us have heard the often-used quote
which is from Lord Acton that power tends
to corrupt--power tends to corrupt; absolute
power corrupts absolutely. And this seems
to be, you know, kind of the case that, you
know, Heroes is, you know, suggesting in some
of these episodes, similar episodes to the
one I just talked about. But power without
the sort of like moral checks and balances
that society ensures is an extremely dangerous
thing. Some of us would adhere to a moral
code just because that's the way we are and
some of us would not, it's like, if this were
to be the case. Some of us would do whatever
it is we wanted to do simply for the fact
that, you know, we could do it and get away
with it. But it says something about like--you
know, these are questions of human nature
and these are questions about, you know, why
society is important and why society functions
the way it is. So, again, like the--the idea
here is that there are interesting scenarios.
Like, they seem very, you know, farfetched
sometimes. When we start to actually think
about it, we can see some of these issues
and like, you know, it causes us, like, you
know, hopefully it causes us to reflect on
some of these deeper things. Speaking of ethics
and this question of right and wrong, there's
one more topic I want to talk about in terms
of Heroes before we kind of open it up to
questions and everything. Really, like, I
think devotees of the history of the show
will probably be familiar with this. This
is the question of Heroes as a show and the
question of originality. People have said
in, like, you know, in the past that, "Oh,
the plot for Heroes is like, you know, the
issue of Uncanny X-Men number 143," where,
like, you know, there's, like, dystopian,
like, you know, history where--excuse me,
not history--future, alternate future were
everyone dies and then someone has to go back
in time to save them. I mean if you follow
the first, like, you know, first, second and
third season of the show, like, you know,
yeah, that kind of is the show in a nutshell.
Like there is this, like, you know, premise
that is very much like, you know, other comic
book plots that have been done before Heroes.
On the one hand--so the issue that we're getting
at is again like creativity versus originality
here. Many people have wondered why there
are so many similarities between Heroes and
the X-Men. This is one of the chapters of
the book and it's kind of fun chapter to read.
Many of the powers in the show are similar
to X-Men. Claire's healing powers are like
Wolverine's healing deal. There's like a guy
who, you know, controls metal like Magneto
does. There's Sylar's like, you know, power-stealing
thing just like Rogue from the X-Men. It goes
on and on and on. So we can also argue--and,
like, this is the other side of the coin--that
old stories can be told and retold in different
ways and possibly new and illuminating ways,
and, you know, such is the nature of stories.
They're told and told again and perhaps something
is added or something is taken away. So, this
question about originality and, like, you
know, whether this is, you know, like a form
of plagiarism or something, like on one level,
like a very, like, a basic functional level
is interesting and, like, you know, I'll be
honest, I wouldn't be happy if someone, like,
took my ideas in writing and, like, passed
it off as their own which, you know, is nowadays
what they call academic writing--I'm just
kidding. The question is not that straightforward
though. It's actually more than like, you
know, when we get past this later of like,
oh, this is just a rip-off of the X-Men, we
start to really think about deeper issues
and one of the things that the chapter talks
about is this question of epistemic responsibility
which is--it's a fancy way of saying, like,
you know, do we--what responsibility do we
have to know things, like to have knowledge
and to, like, you know, be more knowledgeable
about things that we should know about. So,
you know, example, like if you're writing
a show on superheroes, should you know something
about the superhero genre. If you're creating
a show like Heroes, does that--does it seem
a little disingenuous to say, like, I don't
read comic books because I'd be worried that
someone had already thought of my own ideas
and I don't want to know that. That's not
exactly what the show's creator Tim Kring
said, but it's kind of close. So that's his
argument. I mean, it's interesting without
getting into too much of the specifics of
it, but this idea again of like epistemic
responsibility is sort of like what responsibility
do we have to know about the things that we
care about. Like, you know, these are difficult
issues to answer especially when there is
no clear-cut answer like this. You can certainly
argue one way or another but, on a deeper
level, like, you know, and this is--it becomes
a very personal question is, you know, like,
to what extent do you feel responsible for
the knowledge that you have or don't have.
Again, this is like where the philosophy part
of the show comes in. So I suppose the last
example kind of indicates that, you know,
this whole question of like creativity and
originality, it indicates towards that challenges
that comic book heroes and villains kind of
confront, and how that sort of represents
the real-life problems that we have, like,
you know, we deal with in our everyday lives.
The moral decisions that comic book characters
confront regarding their superpowers are not
all that dissimilar from my own struggles
to kind of, you know, make the right moral
decisions in a world that we wish were a little
more black and white. The more we can relate
to the shortcomings of, you know, this sort
of characters, like I've said, the more we
can perhaps relate to this larger than life
figures because they represent, you know,
the best part of ourselves. That's the idea,
like, I think, the appeal behind Heroes and
hence why we enjoy stories about them. You
know, again, to take this back to the idea
of like modern mythology, and why we keep,
you know, repeating these patterns whether
it's like, you know, through, you know, ancient
Greek and Roman figures, or dating back before
those characters or, like, you know, in modern
day. The last point I wanted to make before
we kind of open up to questions is that, you
know, philosophy isn't something that, you
know, just began in a book, although it certainly
is in this book which is available on bookstores
and Amazon now. But, like, the idea is that,
philosophy is something that can be found
everywhere if we know what it is we're looking
for. So the approach of the book is that once
we know to, you know, look for these sorts
of philosophical things, we can start thinking
philosophically and, you know, for a lack
of a better way to put it, like, you know,
the--like when you no longer have that television
show as a point of reference for being into
philosophy at that point, maybe you're so
interested in philosophy that you start, you
know, like, looking for those things, you
know, in other aspects of your life. So that's
more or less what I wanted to talk about.
I want to ask a few questions because what's
really interesting to me besides, you know,
hearing myself talk which I really do like
very much; but I do want to ask you guys also,
you know, some questions that--you know, like,
we're curious about what you think about some
of the stuff we've written. So I'll stop talking
in a minute, but let me just ask these questions,
you know, that you can either answer now or
just think about them like, you know, if you're
at home watching this, like, think about this
question as like the last thing that you hear
from this talk. The first one is that since
I've offered suggestions about how the show
can be philosophically interesting, I'm kind
of curious of, like, the fans of the show,
what is it about the show that's interesting?
Like for me, the show is interesting because,
you know, it's entertaining and I thought
the first season was, you know, very interesting
from a narrative and, like, you know, a philosophical
standpoint but, you know, why is it that we
find the show like Heroes interesting? Like,
what is it? You know, if it's a simple answer
like, you know, such and such character is
cute or if it's something like, you know,
like if there are other, you know, like underlying
things, it's worth stopping to think about
every once in a while. The other question
and some more general question is that--one
of the things I said at the beginning was
that philosophy is something that's eminently
relatable. This book is kind of an example
of that. What are people's conceptions of
philosophy? I'm especially interested for
people like, you know, who maybe like haven't
had much experience with the subject matter
or like really are like outsiders looking
in. Like, I kind of want to know, what does
philosophy--what does the word philosophy
mean to those people? Like, I've heard it,
you know, used in a lot of different ways
but I'm curious. So I'd ask just, like, you
know, think about those things, think about
those, like, two questions and that's all
I have to talk about. And yes, if you have
any questions, let me know. Thanks.
>> Well, I mean when I think of Heroes and
Nietzsche in the same, you know, area--the
first thing that comes to mind for me is Nietzsche's
whole philosophy of the Ubermensch. So my
question for you would be: Which character
do you think would be Nietzsche's favorite--like
most characteristic of the Ubermensch, or
at least his least unfavorite?
>> SHORES: Okay.
>> I mean, and a few characteristics and the
reasons why.
>> SHORES: Okay. Yeah, I like that question
a lot actually. I think, you know, and it's--I'm
prefacing it by saying, you know, here's what
I think Nietzsche would think but, like, you
know, the idea for other people who are curious
about Nietzsche's concept of Ubermensch basically
is that this is an individual who has sort
of gone beyond, like, you know, like the normal
standards of ethics and morality, and it sort
of, like, almost like evolves into a different,
like, ethical being, someone who's like, you
know, is self-creating and therefore like,
doesn't have to listen of what other people,
you know, like tell them who's right and wrong,
but is actually creating those values for
themselves. So, like, potentially, it sounds
very good. Like in theory, it sounds very
good. In practice, sometimes, it's not quite
so simple. So, you know, the question about
like which character might exemplify like,
you know, the Ubermensch, like, you know,
Sylar is a good example. Sylar, like, you
know, he's the superpower, like, you know,
serial killer guy who slices people's, like,
brains open and kills them to take their powers.
But, you know, he is an interesting character,
like not, you know, like, beside the stuff
that he does, but like his rationale for doing
that. At one point he says, you know, that
like normal rule shouldn't apply to him because
he is like the next stage in evolution. Like,
you know, for X-Men fans, like that's pretty
much like their thing. They called mutants
which are the people, the superpowers, like
Homo sapiens superior. So there is this idea
that mutants aren't like, you know, some genetic,
like, you know, whatever like a blip on the
radar screen but they're supposed to be like
the next stage in human evolution. So Sylar
is supposed to represent, at least in his
own mind, that sort of like stage and like,
you know, moral evolution--why should, you
know, like, those kind of, you know, this
like old human morality like apply to him
if he represent something else. Like, another
further example would be like for those of
us that aren't vegetarians--I'm not but, you
know, I understand the argument here that,
you know, like, if you think about what Sylar
does and he's like killing these people to
like, you know, provide nourishment to him,
it's not that dissimilar from like, you know,
how vegetarians argue, Peter Singer, like,
you know, his ethics on animal care and these
sort of things, that, like, you know, we don't
apply the same human rules about killing other
people than we do to killing other animals.
Like, they are living things. Why don't we
think about that? So, like, the idea is that
Sylar, you know, is basically applying that
like thought process that he sees other normal
people who aren't like him as, like you know,
animals, like a cow. So like I'll treat you
the same way that, you know, I treat a cow
that I wanted a hamburger from. That's like
Sylar's kind of like, you know, like moral
standpoint. And the other question about--I
don't--I have to think about that one. Like,
which would be Nietzsche's like least favorite
character?
>> The least favorite.
>> SHORES: Oh, okay. It would have to be--that's
a tough one. Like, I don't know if it's the
best answer but my guess would be like, you
know, Noah Bennet, who is the horn-rimmed
glasses guy, like, I mentioned some of his
things and his, like, moral certainty, but
he's sort of acting on and just sort of like,
almost self-deluded kind of, you know, like
kick here or, you know, I'm doing bad things
but I'm doing them for the purpose of like,
you know, some other good thing. But is that,
like, you know, really the reason or you just
actually like killing and torturing other
people and this is like a convenient sort
of like, you know, like, you know, story to
spin on yourself. So there's that angle, like,
you know, it could fit within like, you know,
Nietzsche's world view. I don't know if it's
perfect but it's an interesting question.
It's a good way to like, you know, think about
like some of these characters and how they
relate to the show and the philosophy so...
>> I have two questions.
>> SHORES: Okay.
>> So my first one is--so I love watching
Heroes because when I watch each episode,
I kind of reflect on, you know, myself and
kind of what you asked. What would you do
in that scenario? And I kind of see bits of
myself in, you know, every character. And,
sometimes, I wonder if because I'm reflecting
on my sense of self through the framework
of the Hollywood writer, if that sense of
self is somehow perverted or less legitimate
or shallower than, say, you know, a sense
of self I developed from a book. So I just
think it's very interesting because, you know,
I watch more TV now than I read a book and,
you know, a lot of my ideas probably come
from the media, and I wonder if the book kind
of reflects on how our views of the world
and ourselves change with media. That's my
first question.
>> SHORES: Okay. I think I could answer that
one because I like that question. I think--the
first thing I thought of was that, you know,
yes, there are--there's no one writer that's
like, you know, you're getting your world
view from if you're like, you know, reflecting
on these things in the show. Like, you know,
there's a lot of, you know, like hands on
the pot for the creative process. Especially,
now, having done the book process, it's not
that dissimilar. Like, you know, you got editors
and you have like publishers who sort of,
like, you know, are changing things. Your
translators too who like--you know, translation
is a big deal too. It's like, you know, a
single word can change like the entire thrust
of like an entire like, you know, passage
or an entire book even. So there are those
decisions and there are decision makers in
that process, so I don't know. Like, you know,
I guess--because I'm going to be a--you know,
I still think of myself as a lit person, like
a literature person. Like, yeah, I'm sort
of biased towards books just because, like,
they, you know, it gives you more time to
reflect on certain things and it's a slower
pace. That's all I'm advocating in terms of
like books as a way to like, you know, derive
like that sense of self, but it's not--books
and television aren't that different sometimes--not
always--and, in fact, not all shows everywhere
for all time but, like, you know, there are
certain TV shows that, again, like I said,
they carry a certain resonance because like
television shows are still stories. Like,
books are stories and they like, you know,
they cause us to reflect on, like, you know,
certain issues. So it's kind of--like that's
my--does that answer the question?
>> Yes, I liked that answer.
>> SHORES: Okay. All right.
>> And my second question is if you can tell
us a little bit more about the three books
that are coming out and which shows should
we be aware of?
>> SHORES: Okay. Let's see. Well, the first
one is--I don't think it's a secret now so
I can just say the--the first one, it's coming
out I think in December or, I don't know,
my publicists can, you know, like, correct
me if I'm wrong, the Alice in Wonderland and
Philosophy which is going to be kind of a
cool one. So it's based on the book by Lewis
Carroll. But, of course, Alice in Wonderland
is now being made into a movie by Disney.
Tim Burton's directing it and it's going to
be kind of this, like, you know, this new
different take on Alice in Wonderland which,
you know, looks potentially very interesting.
So, that's one book that's coming out, you
know, at the end of the year and then following
that one right afterwards is one of my favorite
shows of all time, Arrested Development and
Philosophy, and that one's coming out earlier
next year. But it's--that's a very smart show.
Like, it's funny and I wish that, you know,
people--more people would, you know, watch
it and it would still be on air right now.
But Arrested Development is also coming out
with a movie and, you know, it's--not un-coincidentally,
this book is coinciding with their release
of the movie so that people can get re-interested
in the show in like different ways. And the
most recent one which I'm still writing right
now is 30 Rock and Philosophy which another
show that I like very much, not just because
I love Tina Fey, which I want, in YouTube,
I want people to know that but, like, also
because the show is like very clever, like,
you know, from a narrative standpoint, from
like a construction of like, you know, stories
and things like that. Like, it is a very good
show and it, like, it deals with a lot of
topics not, you know, in a very--it's a comedy
for one thing but it deals with a lot of very
interesting topics like Heroes does. So, like,
the philosophy again is there if you know
how to look for it. So those are the three
for now.
>> Just to debate possibly your choice of
the Ubermensch character, I think you should
also take into consideration on Nietzsche's
ideas about magnanimity and how the Ubermensch,
even though he is all powerful, well, at least
in the sense of creating his own values, he
does not need to express his power by destroying
others unlike people who are weaker and the
way that they feel that they can--you know,
the only course of showing--the only option
of showing their power is by destroying other
people. So, that's really all I have to say.
>> SHORES: Okay. No, I agree with it. Can
I ask you a question? Just out of curiosity,
like, which characters do you think like,
you know, would be your choice for like the
Ubermensch or the--oh, okay. All right. Fair
enough. But you can read the book and kind
of like get a good, like, jumping start on
that. But no, you're right about the--it's
good to point out that like aspect of the
Ubermensch too which--Ubermensch, like, you
know, like roughly translated is like "over
man." So it's this idea again, like, we've
been talking about, like, you know, mutants
and Homo sapiens superior, it's that idea
that this is somehow someone who has like
evolved to, like, you know, over like, you
know, what normal, like, you know, man--human
morality is. So, yeah, I don't really have
anything to add to what you said other than
you're right and I agree, and I think it's
an interesting way to, like, you know, keep
thinking about the--like the tie-in between
Nietzsche and the show.
>> Hey, Tyler, thanks for coming.
>> SHORES: Yeah, thanks.
>> I have a question about the statement you
made from Socrates that evil is just another
way of saying misinformed. Why do you think
it is then that all of the evil characters
are positioned as more intelligent or more
informed?
>> SHORES: That's...
>> They're always sort of the CEOs of the
evil companies or the masterminds and the
good people are always sort of bumbling around
and not--and unaware.
>> SHORES: No, that's a good question. Like,
I was actually thinking about that while I
was talking about it and there was more I
wanted to say. So, like, I'm glad you brought
that up, which is I think there is a difference
between, like, you know, not necessarily like
ignorance or like lack of knowledge so much
as moral ignorance. Moral ignorance is a different
thing. Like, it's this idea. And, like you
know, like you've mentioned, like the show
is, like the villains of the show, the people
who are doing the worse things, like always
seem to be in this position where like, you
know, it seems like they do know better, like
they are the decision makers. Like the original,
the company which is kind of like this--I
don't know what it's called--like, you know,
the CIA type of--no, that's not right. Like,
just like a, you know, secret group of, you
know, superpower people who are--who decided
that they're going to be making the decisions
that, like, are going to be secretly shaping
society. So they've decided that because they
have powers, all of a sudden, they have like
this sort of moral certitude as well and,
like, you know. And at some point in the first
season, they're kind of talking about it that,
you know, this group of people, it was great
for awhile. It was like the super-friends.
Like, you know, they're doing all this things
that was--that were right and good, and then
somewhere along the way, you know, it's--things
started to gray. Like, you know, people started
to lose their way and then things got really
bad and then, like, you know, now, it became
this in-fighting sort of thing between, you
know, like the people who think they know
right versus the people that, you know, like,
they think they know right. So...
>> So maybe it's just a shift of moral framework
from greater good and smaller good. I mean,
if they're doing what they think is right
in the greater good sense, in the smaller
good sense such as blowing up New York City,
not so good.
>> SHORES: Yeah, I mean, yeah, not so good.
It's kind of like, you know, again, the thing
I keep thinking about is that, you know, the
people who do the worst are the ones that
think they're doing the best good. Like, that's
sort of--you know, that's interesting from
the whole point of the show. It's like it
says something about like, you know, the sort
of like moral, like, you know, blindness that
sometimes we have. We feel that we're really
right about something. Like, it should be
a cautionary tale. "Cautionary Tales" is one
of the names of the episodes. So like these
are, like, you know, things that Heroes wants
us to be aware of, like, you know, when we're,
you know, like when we get past the point
of just enjoying it, it's like a dramatic
tension sort of thing. Like, we understand
it from this point of view. Like, you know,
how can--like I certainly have, like, you
know, how can we wonder to ourselves, how
can we not wonder to ourselves like you know,
how can I be so wrong about something that
I feel so right about? Like that's kind of
the, like the thing that many of those characters
have. Many usually get to that point of asking
that question but, you know, I feel like that's,
you know, something that, if at least, you
know, if we take that away from the show,
like, you know, at least, we're slightly in
a better position for having seen that. Is
that kind of your...
>> Last point I want to make is it's nice
to have a show that makes it so gray because
I wonder if in real life, it is as gray. I
mean when you think about overseas tyrants,
pirates, scammers, I'd say a large percentage
of the amount of evil that's done in the world
is done knowingly and not from this sort of
morally gray characters that think they're
doing right but aren't. I don't think that
kind of conflict exists in real life. It's
a creation or fabrication of...
>> SHORES: No, your right. That's also why,
like, you know, it's fiction at the end of
the day, right? So, like, you know, fiction
is kind of comforting in that sense where,
like, you know, we want to believe that people,
like, you know, bad people do struggle, you
know, with things. We want to believe that
it's like, you know, it's sometimes black
and white or there is gray. But, yeah, sometimes,
you know, bad people are just bad people in
real life but, like, you know, it's--the whole
idea of the show is that you want to believe
that there's this, you know, like this chance
that bad people can be stopped and bad people
can be recognized and, you know, like pointed
out as villains, and in real life, it doesn't
always work that way so...
>> Thanks.
>> SHORES: All right. So we're out of time.
So thank you again for everyone for your attention.